[Music]
Um, yeah. So, my name is Mike Chambers.
I'm going to pick you up a little bit
there. So, I'm from Queensland in the
eastern part of Australia, but that's
okay. Um, yeah, very happy to be here.
So, I'm a developer advocate for Amazon
Web Services. Um, and I completely and
utterly and only and totally spe
specialize in generative AI. Used to be
machine learning. Now it's generative
AI. Um, I'll be talking about why this
slide is up here in a moment. Any
tabletop RPG players in the room?
There's got to be at least one or two.
There are some. Randall, you were saying
you were before. Okay. It doesn't matter
if you don't get that, but I will be
showing some code. Um, and what I'm
going to be showing is how to get the
code and how to get into production. So
if you're a developer, this is how you
can get your code and get it to
cloudscale. If you're a leader, then
this is how you can get your developers
to get their code and get it into clouds
scale. Um just a little bit about the
kinds of things that I've done in the
past. Um so um I was incredibly
fortunate a couple of years ago to work
with Dr. Dr. Andrew Ing um and some
colleagues from um AWS on this course.
This is the fundamentals of LLMs. Um
over 370,000
people have taken this course so far. It
was the first of its course of its kind.
I also got to play um Transformers with
Andrew, which is cool. And if you get
the reference there, I'm playing with
Transformers. Okay. And if you don't
know who this is, um that's Optimus
Prime. Okay. I think I'm holding um I
What's the other one called? Um
anybody
Megatron. Thank you. Yes. Yes, that's
right. Um so, um let me jump into it.
Let me jump straight into it. Um, some
of you saw that code was coming and code
is coming. Now, everything I'm going to
show is pre-recorded because Wi-Fi,
right? We know that. Um, but everything
that I'm showing also is in real time.
So, what I want to show first of all is
just something super super simple. This
is a single Python function, a single
Python file, um, which contains an
agent, right? And it's the agent I'm
going to use for the demonstration
moving forward. This is where we get to
dice rolling and TRPG. Um, the idea here
is that I want to do a simple agent with
a simple tool that's not getting the
weather because we know how to do that.
Um, so in this code here, it doesn't use
any frameworks or anything at all. It's
actually kind of inefficient. Um, but I
have this one what we'd call a tool
here. This is my tool. Um, it's how to
roll a dice. Essentially, it's a random
number generator. Um, but I'm calling it
a dice roller. Um, and you can see here,
um, if you if you're, uh, familiar with
this, it's using a llama, um, and it's
using the, um, uh, the Llama 3.1 8
billion parameter model, super tiny,
just running on my laptop. This is
literally an agent running on my
machine. Um, so if we skip through here,
I've got some things which I've sort of
collapsed down for brevity. This is a
simple agent. It's an agentic flow.
We're going to talk more in detail about
what agents are in a moment. I have my
system prompt where I tell it um what
tools it's got available. Um I then also
actually do include some examples as
well. The reason I include examples
again it's a tiny little model and it
just needs a little bit of a helping
hand to understand how to use these
tools um for example to roll a D20. A
D20 this is going to come up again in
this session. So I'll tell you now it's
a 20sided dice. Um if you want to get
one we have them on the AWS stand. Come
and see us afterwards. you can have an
IRL D20, but we're going to have an
agent which will roll it for us. Um, so,
um, let's just open up the terminal. I'm
just going to run this locally so you
can see the kinds of things that my
agent is agent is going to do. Um, so
I'm just running my Python code here.
Um, and you can see it's waiting for my
prompt. So, I'm going to waiting for my
input. I'm going to tell it um, okay,
this is some terminology here from
gameplay. Um, roll for initiative and
add a dexterity modifier of five. that
means something to the few people that
put their hands up in the room. Um, but
it basically means that what I've done
is I passed in my natural language into
the agent. It's used its large language
model and its language understanding to
figure out what I meant by that. It's
then looked at the tools that it's got
available. The tool it has available is
to roll a dice. And then it's performed
that action. And then we've got an
outcome here. So it's rolled a d20. Um,
it's come back with a random number of
10. It's added five to it. I've got my
output of 15. So, this is a simple
really simple exp uh example of what an
agent and how an agent's structured and
what an agent can do. I know it's just a
random number generator, but I think
it's pretty exciting. So, I want to take
this code though, which is all running
on my machine at really low scale, and I
want to make this uh cloud scale. I want
to get this production ready. So, that's
what I'm going to look at next. So let's
um yes let's get back into slides just
for one moment and I want to talk about
the anatomy of an agent. We've just
looked at it running there but let's
look at the anatomy of an agent and as
we're doing this each one of these
things uh we actually have to get into
the cloud running at cloud scale so that
this is the components that we need to
scale and so the first thing I think is
probably the obvious thing is the model.
This is actually super simple and super
easy for us to do. Um, as in they exist
already, so we can just go ahead and use
those. But this is a natural language
understanding. Of course, we need this
to be able to run our agent. Um, the
next thing that I've got on my list,
this is my list. There's probably other
things you could add to this, but I
think this is a minimum list that you
need for an agent. Uh, you need a
prompt. So, you need something to
explain to the agent why it exists in
the world and what kinds of things it
can do. Give it a personality, for
example. Um, next a loop. So this is the
agentic loop. So this is the ability for
the agent to be able to um think
essentially. So it it looks at the input
and it can then process that input. It
then needs to go and use a tool. But
then it needs to evaluate whether that
tool actually answered the question or
not. It needs to figure out if it needs
to go and run another tool. It needs to
loop around. It really is nothing much
more than a while statement, if while,
whatever with some strings flowing
around. A lot of this stuff is just
string manipulation, but we need that to
be hosted and and cloudscale. Next up,
history. This is a really important one
actually, and I've had a couple of deep
conversations about this recently. Um,
when I say history, and I talk about
conversational history, people think of
that as like, okay, well, I'm asking my
agent to do something today, and
tomorrow I want it to remember what I
asked it yesterday. It's actually a
little bit more deeper than that. the
actual conversational history inside of
an agent is is crucial to the running of
the agent. So when we ask it that
question u such as rolling you know
rolling for initiative or whatever it
might be um that goes in and then it
does some reasoning steps right it
decides what it wants to do and then it
goes and calls a tool and the results
the stuff that we were talking about
before in the loop but it needs to
remember those things that it that it's
done so that um it's each next step it
can do that within the context um of
what it's done before. So history is and
conversational history at a low level is
actually really important. Um and then
finally I'm going to have tools here. So
these are of course uh how our agent has
agency to be able to go and perform
something in the outside world. So
another important part are there other
components of agents? Probably yes. Yes
there absolutely are. But this I think
is the base fundamentals. You need these
things in order to be able to have the
minimal viable product I guess of a of
an agent. So I'm here from AWS. Let me
tell you about what AWS can do to host
these agents at clouds scale. The first
one I mentioned it before as being easy.
Obviously anybody who works for a model
laboratory would say actually making
agents uh making models is actually kind
of tricky but they've done it for us
right so the models exist. We've got
anthropic. We've got the Amazon Nova
model. And this icon here represents
Amazon Bedrock. So bedrock is a suite of
capabilities that allow us to be able to
build uh generative components into the
applications that we're building. So we
can just take these components, slot
them in and build something. We have
models from a number of different
leading providers, Amazon like I said,
Anthropic, Meta, Mistral, um AI21 Labs,
we have a number of different models
available. You can plug them into your
system. So that's the kind of the easy
bit. Um let's now build up the actual
agent itself. And so for that I have
Amazon Bedrock agents and Amazon Bedrock
agencies fully managed. There's no
infrastructure to manage with this. You
can just put your configuration in and
it will be cloudscale. So the answer to
the question that I'm here to answer is
actually really straightforward. We're
just going to go and use this service.
Now inside of that we have uh the
configuration that we're going to have
for our agent. Now um I have put here
instruction. Instruction is the
terminology we use. This is again the
personality of the agent. It's a bit
like the prompt. It's not quite the
prompt because it gets combined with a
prompt template to be the actual prompt,
but this essentially for all intents and
purposes is our prompt. That prompt
template, by the way, if you're
interested, you can absolutely go and
edit that if you want, but you get
delivered a default prompt template with
the model that you've selected. Um, then
we need to have well, all of those
things I talked about with the loop and
the history, conversational history,
it's all taken care of. So, that's all
just inside of the service. But then
from our configuration standpoint, the
next thing is the action group. So this
is where we connect into tools. So an
action group is a collection of tools.
That's what you can see that as. I've
got a couple of different action groups
here just to show that you can have more
than one. We only need one because I
only have one dice rolling tool. Um, and
you see in the middle here, we've got
Lambda. So hopefully you're familiar
with Lambda. It's a a function as a
service. It scales super well. It
handles that scaling for you. It's just
the way the service works and it's a
perfect place to host these kinds of
tools and therefore your tools can do
anything that Lambda can do which is I
mean I'd be interested if you can find a
use case that Lambda can't do. There are
some but anything anything that your
code can do in there um your tool can do
including reaching out to the outside
world reaching to other AWS services
sending an email launching a rocket
whatever it is that you want to do.
Actually I'd really like to see
launching a rocket. I say that from time
to time. We need to go do that. We need
to build that. So I've whistle stop
tored through those components. The
important things to remember there are
the action groups really because that's
maybe terminology you haven't come
across before. Um so now I'm going to
dive into the console and we're going to
build this. Again, this is all real
time. I'm advancing it forward with my
clicker, right? But but in between those
things, it's all real time. There are
some people in the room that are now
saying, "Well, hang on a minute. you
were saying, "Ship this to production."
I'm not going to ship to production with
ClickOps. That's awful. And you're
right. It is. And so all the things that
I'm going to show you are all possible
as well with Terraform or Palumi or
Cloudformation or SDK or SAM or whatever
infrastructure is code framework that
you want to use. So bear that in mind.
But I'm showing you in the console
because it's easier to look at. All
right. So what I need to do is just uh
I'm at the Amazon bedrock part of the
AWS console page. I've gone down to
agents on the bottom of the left or the
down on the left hand side. And this
next little part's going to be very
bouncy ball kind of easy stuff. I'm
going to click create an agent. Okay. So
then I get to name it and I get to give
it a description so that six months from
now when I go into my console and like
what was that agent for? I said, "Oh,
that's what that agent's for." So, it's
always a good idea to use descriptions
in anything you do inside of AWS. So, um
I'm saying it's an agent to help me play
tabletop RPG. If those are the questions
you have, by the way, we definitely go
to the booth afterwards. We can talk a
lot about this kind of stuff. Um so,
I've got that set up. Um I scroll down.
You remember one of the pieces of
configuration that we needed was to
connect it to our model. And so, I get
to choose models here. I've got the
Amazon Nova models. I'm going to select
the anthropic um haiku 3.5 3.5 haiku. Um
it's a small it's a capable model. It's
fast. It's probably more than we need
for this very simplistic um agent, but
it's a good one. And so here I'm adding
in those instructions. If you remember
before the instructions get combined
with the template to become the actual
prompt. So you're a games master who can
help me play tabletop RPG games. That's
probably what you're going to take away
from this, right? everybody's going to
go away and start playing um these
games. Um so I've defined what I want my
agent to be. So I click save so that
I've got it ready to go. And the next
thing I have to do is action groups. So
once we've done that, yes. So we can we
scroll down to action groups. And this
is where I'm going to connect in my
logic with um the code execution that we
were talking about before. So let's
click add. Guess what? It wants a name
and a description. We're familiar
territory here. Um and so we can give it
this description. Now these descriptions
are read by the large language model so
that it can figure out what this tool is
for. Um and this is sort of this new
paradigm of programming right so in
terms of definitions and schemas for how
these things work. We actually write in
natural language in here so that LLM can
read it and figure out if that's what
they want to do or what that's what they
want to use. So we've got our action
group as a whole. Now let's go and add
in the actual code. We have a few
different options here. And this option
here is the recommended one, which is to
use lambda, which we saw in that diagram
before. Also, with this quick start
here, it'll set up the lambda function
for you. It'll do all the comm uh the
permissions for you. Um, and it will
hook it up to the agent for you. So,
it's a really quick way to get started.
Definitely recommend using that. Um, and
now we come down to define the actual
tool itself that we want. This is my
dice roll or my roll dice. I can I flip
between the two. This one's going to be
called roll dice. And again, we're
giving it a description. This
description is important because it
tells the LLM what uh what this does and
whether it wants to use it or not. Um
and so it's got, you know, roll the dice
with a certain number of sides. So we
need a way to pass in those certain
number of sides. This was all in the
code before as well. Um and so if I
scroll down here, I get the parameters
and I get to again just describe these
parameters that I want. Just expanding
this out because I'm zoomed in for the
screen's sake. Um, and I get to add in
my parameter. And guess what? I give it
a name and I give it a description. And
again, the description is something
which is read by the large language
model. We're following the pattern here,
right? So, it knows what this is for.
Um, and I'm going to set this up as an
integer value because I only have a, you
know, an integer number of sides on any
dice. Um, and I'm going to say it's
required. I need this to be there. I
need to tell the model that if you're
using this tool, you must provide me
with an integer for that. Okay, I know
I'm going fast, but I'm respectful of
your time and I want to show you this
working. So, let's click create. Again,
this is real time. It's going to go
ahead and build that Lambda function for
me, integrate the permissions for me,
and have everything set up. And so, once
I save this and scroll down, I can get
back to my action group, dive into my
action group again, and what I have
inside of there is now a link to the
Lambda function. So code's coming back
and we just need to put this logic into
our Lambda function so it can work for
us. Now I'm going to do a little bit of
quick and dirty here. I'm going to take
the boiler plate that it provided for me
and I'm just going to whack in some um
function to allow us to do this dice
roll. Um so here's my Python inside my
Lambda function. So this is just inside
the console. You'll notice that as I'm
coding here, um, Amazon Q developer is
actually built into the console into
this code editor and it'll be making
suggestions for me in terms of what code
I might want to put in. So, I'm going to
import random, which of course is
necessary. If you're familiar with
Lambda already, then you'll know that
you get this event that comes in and
that event sort of triggers how this
thing is going to work. Um, and we have
here a function which is passed in. So,
it's telling us which function we want
to use. Um, and it sends in some
parameters as well. So, let's um rattle
through putting some code in. I'm going
to say, okay, well, if the function that
we're calling is roll dice, um, then I
want to basically go and grab the number
of sides, generate my random number, and
off I go. So, with it being real time,
you have to wait for me to actually
type, um, which is the way it is. And
you also have to wait for me to paste
this one because I'm less good at doing
this one by hand. Um, but in it comes.
And we're nearly there.
So the next thing I need to do is just
format my response. So my response body
here is going to have my um my random
number generated. In this particular
case, Q developer um inside of this IDE
knows exactly what I want to do by this
point because I know you you want to
play RPG. Um so it's written the code
for me. So I can just tab select tab
complete on that. Um and then with a
little bit of tidy up just so that it
works with the boiler plate that was
there. Just going to indent that. Um,
then I can go ahead and click the deploy
button. Um, and that's all I need to do.
So now I can go and click the deploy
button. Excellent. And that's all I need
to do. So that Lambda function now is
being saved into Lambda environment.
That's all you need to do. Everything
should be ready to go. So if I go back
to my agent, um, I'm going to have to
prepare my agent. And I just want to
talk through this just for one moment.
Um, this is a production ready
environment, right? So we have the agent
and then we have alias ids in here. We
got the whole um software development
life cycle thing going on. So you can
have different aliases as you're um uh
publishing out your agents. Um but once
we've prepared that, we should be able
to test it over on the right hand side.
And so let's ask it the question. I'm
going to use a little bit more flowery
language in this case because we want to
um stretch the model tiny bit. We're not
really stretching anything at all. Um,
and as soon as we've got this and I
figured out how to spell initiative, um,
it will roll the dice for us. And as you
might expect, it's going to work. But
what's happening here is that this agent
is now fully hosted in a fully managed
environment. It's going to work for us
at cloudscale. And our answer comes back
with a quick 15. I just want to go and
wrap this up then. Um, if you're
interested in learning more about this,
so I mentioned before about the courses
we have on deep learning AI. These
courses are totally free. You get a free
AWS environment to be able to play
around with Amazon Bedrock agents
completely risk-f free. I'll put this QR
code back up in a moment as well. Um,
thank you so much. Um, so please come
and talk to me following my prompt
template. If you want to talk about
anything more than just this at
cloudscale, MCP servers at cloudscale, I
definitely want to talk to you. If you
want to talk about our new open-source
SDK for developing model first agents,
this is the stuff I hadn't got time to
fit into this presentation. Um, if you
want an in real life D20, then come and
join me on the AWS stand in the expo
hall. If you want to talk about anything
else, then thank you so much for your
time and I will let you get to lunch.
[Music]